Hi, this is relate well, I guess yeah, yes, it is relief
I heard you say it is important to think I heard Jocko say this too. How do you think meaning?
How do you talk to yourself do you ask yourself questions? Do you think by talking to others?
What do you believe is the most valuable method for becoming a clear thinker and communicator?
That's a deep question. I actually think it's pretty easy to answer it is easy answer. I think I can answer in one word
Go detach
That's that's that's how I think
you you can't you got to step out you got to step back mentally you gotta step back look at what's going on and
Think of and that's where you can think about it. That's where you can figure out. What's going on if you can do that
You're there. If you can't do it. You don't even know you're not doing it. That's the problem when you're not detached
You don't even know you're not attached. You're in the storm, and you don't even know it
That's out for that's exactly right
But I think you know for people that maybe don't fully understand what that means right the this idea of the tattoo
which you've obviously talked a lot about on here and which is such a key thing for decision making
it's
The the I think the key thing there is is to make sure that you're not you're not clouded by you know this
Emotional attachment to plans which we often talked about with our
leaders in the SEAL team so I am
Emotionally invested in a plan that I came up with I spent hours, or days or weeks or months. You know involved in
And I want that to succeed of course, but but is that you know I gotta have that realistic assessment
And that's what the detachment really requires is that you pull yourself, not just physically away
You know out of the weeds are to say okay?
Let me think about this in the strategic picture
But you really you take away that emotional investment that you have to to maybe even whether it's a plan sometimes
It's a team member as well
And if you have you know someone that you just have a close relationship with that you you know that whether there are a relative
Of yours or you had a long-standing
Relationship with and and that maybe you've gotten too close to them and you can't see that that you know they become more important than
the mission and they're dragging the rest of the team down you're not making the
Call either tighten them up or let them go if that's that's the right case so I think what that really requires is
You got emotionally pull back. It's it's a mental thing to really have a brutally honest assessment of the situation
That's that's independent from any kind of
Previous bias that you might have had
that's interesting there because
Even if you know like oh yeah, I'm gonna detach oh not that easy yeah, like yeah
Go through the motions. You can't be like hey. I'm gonna detach. I'm detached right now meanwhile
You're just like I said clouded by the emotional part that you're like kind of one foot in emotionally, so you're technically not detached
So it doesn't work
You know what else is a good way to think is to listen
You listen to what people are saying. I've been thinking about how Moore how he said if you listen you know
Twice as much you know everything that you know and you know everything that the other guy knows yeah, that's a great
That's a great thing, but if you're sitting in a you know conversation
I mean from a business perspective if you're in a meeting and and there's a conversation going on if you're in the conversation
You're talking you're adding your piece. Well, then you're you're not detached
You're in it, but if you sit back and you listen and you hear what's going on you can assemble
You know thoughts better